right Wingers are very afraid of change
they're very afraid of others they're
afraid of difference and so it's really
effective to use authoritarianism as a
way to maintain control even if they
want freedom and liberty because you
tell them as a right winger as a
right-wing elected official folks all
these things you're afraid of
Twitter censoring conservatives and
brown people storming the border and uh
what does Trump call them insane asylums
emptying out into the United States and
immigrants taking your jobs and China
taking your stuff and whatever
in order to get them to agree to the
authoritarianism
you say I will use the authoritarianism
to uh help protect you from all these
things I have made you afraid of so fear
gets them to go with the
authoritarianism even when they say I
like freedom I like Liberty